why am I the only one who can't figure
out how to use the Bluetooth earphones
you see the Bluetooth up in the right
hand corner now I don't have a Bluetooth
in my right hand corner oh as it
searches for devices it doesn't seem to
find these little suckers press the
button and hold the button
and don't take them out yeah is there
like a little button on there on the
back button ain't no money
nah nah nah nah dog I ain't got no
button oh wait okay
I haven't noticed that sorry my dogs
decided she has to be a part of this so
she's gonna be wow me that's fine that
noise you hear is her not me farting and
barking I can't get my uh my mic to work
is it turning on I can't hear any of
these you can't you can't hear us hold
on you can hear everybody can hear but
I'm the only one that can't hear you
know great I'm calling you here's Megan
calling me
hey Mike this is funny hey so um just
check your sound preferences because I
bet I bet you have your output going
through your microphone which is why you
can't hear us so if you go to assistant
preferences
wow are you guys hearing like crazy [ __ ]
sorry guys it's probably me
oh [ __ ] I forgot something I'll be right
back
um
great uh okay well after all that fun
let's get started
[Music]
foreign
Sunny podcast now if you'll notice we're
um we're not in studio we're here in our
homes doing this uh Zoom [ __ ] again
and um I'd like to bring up why and I
have a couple of questions
um it appears that my co-hosts Glenn and
Charlie uh were both sick Charlie's been
sick for a while Glenn is now sick uh
with some sort of flu type cold and or
covered we don't know but we have
established that both of them are more
healthier than I am and yet here I am
I have more beef than you do with this
exact issue Rob and here's why yes
because Charlie
uh can I say you just please what you
just went through please okay so Charlie
who somehow was the healthiest of all of
us according to Dr Kipper and you know
I've got beef with that too but we can
get to that later
um
you know got hit with covid uh pretty
hard and I who was not as healthy as
Charlie currently have covid
and I feel nothing
well I mean if you want to go Tit for
Tat this is your second bat with covet
it was my first I think I went a good
two wow years without even without even
a sniffle and his first time I was sick
in quite some time uh secondly I think I
was pretty worn down from that tour that
we did when I got it so uh you know it's
like uh already pretty run down and then
it's it crept into me now we all did the
tour we all did the tour yeah but you
guys had already had coveted so you had
coveted immunity uh I did not so I was
just like uh naked as the day I was born
out there you know real risky and you
know it takes a lot to sing you know to
really just get out there and sing every
night you're really kind of pushing the
lungs and uh and um and we pushed back
let's admit it we push the liver and uh
if we disprove did we disprove then
Rob's theory that whiskey kills covet if
you like drink enough of it while you're
traveling well I didn't have any at my
cousin's wedding which is I'm pretty
sure is where I got it so maybe if I had
been drinking whiskey I would have been
fine I don't know isn't that amazing we
were around thousands of people I mean
just thousands of people in Philadelphia
and Kentucky yeah hugging and shaking
hands and just getting breathed on left
and right it was so foolish
that's just that shit's just yeah just
we should not have done that we should
not have done that and yet that's not
where Charlie apparently got it I don't
believe so I think it was like my like
uh my aunt's friends being like yeah
it's good to see you Charlie I'm just
like screaming right into my mouth like
this
I've been sick for a long time but
you know
yeah it's always good yeah yeah
if you don't think that Philly accent
sounds like [ __ ] some kind of
ridiculous Victorian England accent
uh what is this
get like get out of my face like I hate
it when people talk right into my face
have you ever
it's loud at a wedding though right it
is like so they're they're blasting the
music so then
you know some someone who like uh
doesn't know me very well wants to say
hi really has to get up in there to to
talk to me and I think that's where the
coven particles were passed back and
forth yeah I I did an experiment the
other day uh this was this was fun
um
I was at some event and this person was
a close talker right and just you know
just kept getting like in my face to
talk and it just it wasn't that loud so
it was not at all necessary for this
person to do this
so I just kept backing up right and what
I decided to do because I was like this
is so funny to me I'm just gonna go in a
circle and see what happens and this
[ __ ] followed me in a circle we
went and we just got kept and I was just
like I'm gonna see how long this will go
on for before this [ __ ] notices
that we're literally going in circles
and we just went in circles and circles
and circles and this person never ever
noticed that I was taking him on a ride
and it was completely bizarre and I just
I luckily it kept me from going crazy
because I was like get out of my face
is so weird that you that you that you
just brought that up because I had
almost the same experience on Saturday
night I was at an event and I had the
same thought where I was like I'm going
to there's a very close talker it was
kind of loud but not loud enough to
justify how close he was and and I know
him like it wasn't a complete stranger
but I but I thought okay how am I going
to navigate This I Gotta I'm gonna take
him on a ride but I did the complete
opposite where I went closer to him
closer and closer and closer and closer
and eventually he started like backing
up to the point where I got all the way
up like up to him and he was like what
are you doing and I was like I was just
trying to get as close to you as
possible and he's like why
and anyway we worked it out that's
that's funnier that's even funnier
that's funny that I feel like that's the
personality difference maybe between you
and I right there like in a nutshell you
know like that's your move my move is to
is to like keep backing up and just
going in circles and your move is just
all right well if we're going forward
let's go forward and like let's just go
all the way forward because buddy I'm
ready to touch noses if you want yeah no
I'll [ __ ] kiss you I'll kill on that
top lip just to just just see what
happens that's right and I just stand
there and take it I just take it man
like I take every person who wants to
talk right into my mouth I take it
I didn't wear a mask at the wedding
because I I was like I don't want to be
like the only like celebrity guy there
and then he's got a mask on and people
are like hey Charlie thinks he's better
than us he's gonna cover his face you
know like I don't know just like weird
like I want everyone to be happy at my
own expense now I want no one to be
happy because I was sick for too long so
that is that's really funny
I want everyone to be happy I had a good
time at the wedding what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do okay he's gonna talk about this
erratic life man this uh Dennis Reynolds
erotic life yeah God
every time we watch an episode
it just blows me away how weird this
show is a really funny so weird really
so weird it's so weird do you guys want
me to recap what happens for people yeah
you're doing that a little bit of
structure back because remember the
structure
all right so yeah we have a little bit
of structure
um Dennis Reynolds an erotic life is
from season four episode nine
um it aired on October 23 2008 it was
written by Rob mcelhenney Glenn Howerton
and Scott martyr it was directed by Fred
Savage Dennis enters rehab while Mac and
Frank try to authenticate his erotic
Memoir Dee and Charlie live in each
other's shoes for the day
what were you even doing in that crawl
space Charlie well
Waters I was minding my own business I
was also trying to do a little light
reading and then I was putting some
cheese in the rat trap putting the
cheese in the rat traps yes can I smell
your mouth what you were eating the
cheese weren't you out of the rat traps
no well yes I mean I was eating the old
cheese to test it see why the rats
weren't eating it he was doing such
weird things Charlie I do weird things
name another thing that you think is
weird well I caught you stealing a bunch
of coins out of the fountain at Logan
Circle uh I was acquiring a little bit
of cash to pay my Spidey what spine to
spy in the waitress of course I have a
spy is that normal do you know what shut
up and give me my book back please hey
guys what book you keep going on and on
about nothing you don't need to see oh
my God
oh
these are my these are my Memoirs
Charlie you found my book I wrote a
Memoirs hey guys charlie found my
Memoirs your Memoirs I've been keeping
track of all my sexual exploits and I
was gonna unleash them in the world in a
fiery blaze of eroticism whoa whoa whoa
slow down a second Dennis
you wrote a book well it's more of a
tale of redemption told through my
erotic travels giddy up man that's
amazing that's good stuff right yeah but
then one day the book just sort of went
mysteriously missing Charlie what the
hell were you doing with it well uh
since you can't read I'm guessing he was
masturbating to your picture goddamn
jacking off to my phone no that is not
at all you know what are you doing to me
why are you doing this you've been
riding me now you're accusing me of
things you just don't get it you don't
know why I do the things that I do it's
nuts you don't know how hard I got it
dude pretty tough your life is pretty
hard I'll tell you what I just have to
walk a mile on my shoes so I'm trying
your old buddy Charlie on for size you
want to walk a mile in your shoes
because I can't handle your big tough
life I will that sounds fine to me I
will do that oh my God shut up Dennis
what's the name of this book ah
Dennis Reynolds an erotic life I'll tell
you what in my covet Haze I watched a
lot of uh movies uh which that's you
know the one good thing about it is like
just having some time to just be like
well I can't do [ __ ] so let me watch
some stuff and I watched some like
some
I won't like say every movie but I
watched some what are considered really
high-end sophisticated
uh you know like movies from Europe that
are very funny
and they were brilliant that blew me
away
but out of watching all those movies and
as much as I love them nothing made me
laugh harder than Danny running into the
room to eat that cat food at the end of
the night when those cats start howling
Charlie no wonder if reeks in here you
have open cans of pee everywhere well
I'm sorry but you do not want to use
that bathroom okay now eat one of these
all right you're gonna want to hop a
little glue and drink some beer
this is cat food Charlie oh dude I can't
explain it all right there's some sort
of weird chemical reaction that happens
when you combine cat food beer and glue
it makes you feel like extremely sick
and tired and you're able to fall asleep
why would I want to make myself
extremely sick and tired because there's
gonna be about 50 cats Helen outside
that window all night long and you have
new idea how about 50 cats can be okay
maybe there wouldn't be cats surrounding
your building if you didn't have open
cans of cat food everywhere I have 50
cats howling outside my window because I
have 10 000 rats running around my
building dude okay
there's a reason to do the things that I
oh
I don't feel good
I'm just starting right on time if I
were you I'd started woofing that [ __ ]
down
I gotta go to sleep
oh I'm not feeling good at all
[Laughter]
there's a certain type of humor
that our show
found and that we were able to get away
with that for me I'm sure not for
everyone for me is a true Belly Laugh
you know it's a true belly laugh and I
would I would argue that this episode
does not work for for many reasons but
even an episode that doesn't work to
have a laugh that
because I'd forgotten I'd forgotten it
came firing it and started wolfing down
the cat food so he could go to sleep and
what's just a funny thing that was I
don't know that did that make any sense
I think I have coveted Brain still I I
cried laugh didn't make sense I I cried
laughed like five different separate
times in this one was when you picked up
the P bucket to show D
um Charlie and it's flashing you start
laughing and I I was laughing at that
then I also laughed when Danny came
firing in with the inexplicably wearing
Mardi Gras beads yeah yeah he's been in
some crazy party yeah I remember us
making that choice and being like let's
just store some Mardi Gras beads on him
and have it be a total mystery we won't
explain it at all but it's just like
he's been at some kind of [ __ ] weird
thing and then but it it's also like the
specificity of like how he he wolfs it
down then he again he gets in bed puts
his back to you and then he like turns
over for a second and he's like like
almost like he's considering turning the
other way and then he's like
and turns back to the direction that he
was going in the specificity of like
some of those choices was incredible and
then I also guffawed
um at all the all the shining stuff but
especially when Dee comes back in and
and Danny's like occupied
[Music]
well this is I mean it's the first yeah
it's the first time we really kind of
peeled back uh the curtains to show you
what was going on uh you know in these
guys and I mean we we alluded to you
know what their life was like and pooped
the bed and you know so but we were
getting deeper and deeper into their
like strange
uh Bromance if you guys remember
this season we had
um
a couple issues it was this episode and
it was Mac and Charlie die
and mac and Charlie die and this episode
were coming in crazy long on time and
for anyone at home who doesn't know what
that means you have a certain amount of
time the episode has got to be what was
it at that time 22 minutes 23 minutes
yeah 22 40 21 and a half it was getting
it's getting shorter and shorter as the
years go by right so at that time we had
about 21.5 minutes whatever it was and
you know the episode was like 30 minutes
and nowadays there's more wiggle room in
television but back then it was pretty
much like no you have to you pretty much
have to hit this time window because we
have all these ads that are paying for
the the eyeballs so
um
so we were we had enough time to fix Mac
and Charlie die because of when we shot
it in the season that we said okay we
can add a bunch of scenes and make a a
two-parter and I think we pitched two FX
doing that for this episode too
and they were like no uh I think well
they didn't like they didn't like
two-parters they they never wanted two
parters that yeah they you know they
always wanted the show to play like you
could watch any episode at any time and
it wasn't tied to anything else
so this is the first time we sort of
coined amongst ourselves a Frankenstein
episode the term a Frankenstein episode
because we had to pull out so much of
this episode
to get it to the run time and we we
pulled out just enough that it made
sense but I think there was a lot more
of me and D
uh
uh of of what we were up to I think
there was more there's there was
definitely more of Sinbad and Rob Thomas
do you guys remember the thing we cut
let's see that I was expecting it I
thought Oh I thought it was in the
episode where where did that that never
exist what did we release it on the DVD
we put it on the DVD did we so Megan
there was a beat where Rob Thomas breaks
Glenn out of uh the psychiatric ward he
says look you got to get out of here
Sinbad's crazy you know and then he
thanks Rob Thomas and he climbs out the
window or something like that and then
Rob Thomas like pulls a gun up and we
pan off of Rob Thomas to the picture of
Sinbad and then blood splatters across
Sinbad's face
you're gonna get out of here Sinbad read
your book and he loved it
of course he loved the book it's a great
book I mean you know you don't get it
he's gonna kill you and then he's gonna
write his own stories using your erotic
Legacy
that's son of a [ __ ] I'll never get
away with it Sinbad gets what Sinbad
wants now come on let's go out the
window I'm doing that but wait Rob
Thomas what about you I mean what are
you gonna do when Sinbad finds out you
help me
don't worry about me man
I'll be just fine
I've seen this so yeah we might have put
it in like we did we put it in the DVD
extra I had the DVDs for the first like
five seasons so I bet I've seen it on
that I also there is a Dennis Reynolds
like short film where he reads from his
erotic Memoirs yeah that was on the
dining scene stuff we started shooting
yeah I gotta send that to you guys how
upsetting was that it's
it's less funny than the episode welcome
to another installment of Dennis
Reynolds an erotic life
let us turn erotically to another
installment of Dennis Reynolds an erotic
life
chapter one
Memoirs with a geisha the least funny
stuff in the episode in my opinion is is
all of the erotic Memoir stuff and the
funniest stuff is I disagree is just I I
mean I don't know the Memoirs are funny
it's so fun the same bad stuff is
probably less funny to us because we
know it's coming I think if you like
when you don't know it's coming and
you're like what the [ __ ] is Sinbad and
Rob Thomas what are they doing in the
show I think no I like to send that
stuff
Sid that's great by the way Sinbad's
amazing
boom
yo Punk oh
we go
what the hell yeah you in hell all right
you know what my name is Sinbad this is
Sinbad's house when you're in cinema
house you my [ __ ]
yeah you know what that is huh
that's Rob Thomas Matchbox 20. sing a
song shut up I also like the little
detail by the way that I I noticed on
this viewing that when you put your
hands up Glenn you have very clearly two
different Stigmata wounds suggesting
that Charlie that um Mac and Frank
couldn't agree and so did one
yeah
yeah
nice little Easter egg for people uh
watching but by the way we tried to get
Bon Jovi for this one
um and we try to use we tried to get
bovine Joni himself
um
to do this with this I think through
Danny because you know we've used Danny
a couple times for that
um you know or had Danny reach it he's
like look you know Bon Jovi's a jersey
guy and he was or no that was the that
was the that comes later that was the
Bruce Springsteen thing was going to do
it he was going to do it yeah yeah yeah
but I don't think I don't know that
bovine Joni ever even got back to us
about it so Mr Reynolds you're
interested in buying our Arena Football
team big time but I want to do business
with Mr Von Joni himself Bon Jovi yeah
Mr bovine Joni himself ma'am I am dying
of very terminal cancer and I would like
to request a private bedside concert
from Mr Bon Jovi now sambora's presence
is not necessary but it would be nice if
he was involved question is this a laser
pointer yes can I have it
anymore you're not negotiating [ __ ]
we're on to the cancer thing now and
that is the way that it's gonna go from
here okay I'm just gonna throw this out
there
I don't think you have cancer what what
are you what are you talking about no
that's that's chemo that's chemotherapy
right there and for the record
when you go through chemo your beard
hair falls out too are you sure I asked
a lot of people I asked my bald Captain
I do the cancer but they was working
until you got in with the [ __ ]
numbers God damn it you know I'm not
even really bald
I have a full head of hair not like him
there's a lot of just screaming at each
other in this episode there's not a lot
of levels you know
Dee and I are just hollering at each
other the whole time the stand-up comedy
sequence though is also really funny so
I don't go to a therapist
Mars if you walk up to the nearest drunk
guy and bump up from behind he always
turns around goes hey man what's your
problem
this guy is great you come here every
night every night huh this is great do
they have food too because I could go
for some food no no food I don't eat
while I'm here well when do you eat I
don't oh why don't you eat dinner do you
gotta eat dinner sometime because when
you perform your nerves make you dry
heave and you better hope that you don't
have any food in your stomach
you're gonna perform all right
now this next lady you all know because
she's here almost every night let's hope
she's got some new jokes this time
everybody put your hands together for
Deandra Reynolds
[Applause]
howdy howdy howdy how's everybody doing
tonight
so you guys what's the deal with those
hands-free headsets that everybody's
wearing in their ears right
it's like hey everybody look at me I'm
one part robot and three parts [ __ ]
I mean am I right that's great I laughed
so hard at all the all the dry heaving
stuff I like completely forgot how funny
that was and I I didn't think anything
was going to top Dee's thing but then
you're you're dry heave at the very end
yeah every cheese cheese is a funny
thing she's a strange thing I always
wonder like what what is cheese where
does it go
that's all put in post right I mean that
was didn't he make it
yeah we like doubled it up and like yeah
did the whole thing yeah we added
something to it we also added the bur
the first thing that when Dee's for on
her first uh thing we added that like
the burp noise Caitlyn's such a good dry
heaver she just does what is that and
then Pat Walsh is great as a as a uh so
you know did Pat write this episode or
no he was just on a writing staff
Roberto rad
who I just ran into uh for the first
time since then so that was that 13
years ago that was two weeks ago he came
up it's that guy the first that guy
stand up yeah oh two weeks ago this guy
I was at someone's house and this man
comes over to me and says I was in an
episode of sunny and it was it was that
man but he also went to high school with
Charlie
he did what a name Roberto rad
who screamed uh Jesus Christ from off
screen when I think that was doing
what's that yeah I think that was our
editor all right yeah and then those are
like editing add-ins right where we're
in the editing room we're like Jesus
Christ
[Music]
we are supported by athletic greens yeah
that's right and as you know I take ag1
every single day primarily because it's
it's lifestyle friendly no matter what
diet I'm on at any given moment because
I want I want an optimized immune system
okay especially for this time of year
well right because Halloween's right
around the corner uh yes that's true but
I'm talking about flu season being right
around the corner I don't need my immune
system all right ag-1 does contain less
than one gram of sugar no GMOs No nasty
chemicals and nothing artificial so
ostensibly you could take it and still
save your daily sugar allotment for
candy okay I'm not I'm not eating any
candy and I'm also not talking about
Halloween I'm talking about viral
infections and I'm trying to keep this
Temple Immaculate so that I can fight
them well athletic greens constantly
updates ag1 based on the latest science
and third-party testing so you're smart
to fend off those germs and all those
crowded costume shops crowded haunted
houses crowded parties Charlie's
throwing a Halloween party this year
yeah I'm gonna have a punch bowl of ag1
at the party okay well let me look at my
calendar because that sounds pretty good
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you a free one-year supply of
immune supporting vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticqueens.com sunny again that's
athleticgreens.com Sunday to take
ownership over your health and pick up
the ultimate daily nutritional insurance
and now word from our sponsor better
help look it's tough to train your brain
to stay in problem solving mode but once
you learn how to do it there's no better
feeling and sometimes you need a good
teacher to help get you there like a
like a therapist yeah I mean therapists
can open you up to thought strategies
that will make it easier to accomplish
your goals no matter how big or small
they may be it's like they teach you
Jedi Mind Tricks sure I mean you don't
learn like telekinesis but listen guys
if you're if you're looking to try
therapy better help is a great option I
mean I've had great experiences with
therapists honestly they taught me tips
and tricks I think about every single
day and I no longer feel stressed like I
used to like you'd feel if you were
stuck hanging upside down on an ice
planet um okay look whatever childhood
Epic Fantasy we're drawn from here just
know that better help is convenient
accessible affordable and entirely
online and switch therapists anytime you
can
when you want to be a better Problem
Solver therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com sunny today to get 10 off
your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny
[Music]
one thing that was so funny to write and
perform was uh Danny and I in the movie
theater just trying to be the most
obnoxious people that could ever
possibly be in a movie theater and to do
everything that everybody has at one
point experienced in a movie theater but
like put them all into one or two people
was really fun
thank you
hey dude where you been I'm in rehab
dude oh yeah hey that whole Joby thing
went South so I think we're just gonna
scrap the whole book we'll do
I got another call Buddy
hello
are you looking for
oh this is Mac you got the wrong number
yeah no it's no problem what number were
you trying to call
shh hello Frank you gotta get me out of
here man we're
all I mean rehab
I'm in a movie
bro is about to get naked so I gotta go
and the person who's calling Terry uh do
you remember who that is
it's either ball cap guy the way the
or is it who was actually playing well
it's a random call that was like part of
the joke oh that's right it's random he
calls looking for Bill and then I must
take him for Bill and then it turns out
he's Terry and then we make arrangements
to chat after after
a random guy but by the way you and
Danny have a chemistry in that scene
which is
I feel like we haven't played that
energy a lot and it's really funny it's
uh
yeah you're very combative with him in a
fun way yeah yeah um but okay do you
remember what actor what actor was
playing Terry on the other end no clue
no clue I'm almost 100 sure that is that
that is Glenn
I think that that is Glenn with a
modulated voice
yeah I could tell by the delivery yeah I
thought it was some chick who are you
talking to I'm talking to Bill and
anyway so oh I'm sorry no it's Terry
sorry about that Terry anyway these cat
people Harry because I kept calling them
what number did he want would you please
shut up what's up yeah I got some dick
in a movie theater turn around like that
yeah nice talking to you all right I'll
talk to you afterwards bye right yeah
yeah he's not it's not that dissimilar
to the guy that I played
um when the guy was trying to check his
voicemails in that sweet D has a heart
attack episode and he calls in and you
answer the phone in his office that was
that was also just a voice modulated
version of me you guys can yeah Glenn
you can change your voice in a way that
someone won't recognize it I feel like
maybe I don't know I I think I can but
then I do it and then I'm like oh it
sounds exactly like me still somehow
well you guys didn't even realize that
that was Glenn in the episode and you
just watched it yeah you don't really
hear the other voice though that well
it's like turned down but you're yeah
right you're right you can you can hear
well let's we'll put it in the Pod and
people can see if they can determine for
themselves but but what you were saying
about the obnoxiousness of those people
like that was so I feel like this
question we're constantly answering on
It's Always Sunny in the quote and the
answer the question is always who does
that you know what I mean like when you
go through life and you see people like
act a certain way you're like who the
[ __ ] who acts this way who does this and
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia is the
answer to that question you know what I
mean that's it's it's been it's been
such a delight to uh Purge that uh from
myself because I've been in movie
theaters where people are basically
doing exactly what you guys are doing
and I'm like are you [ __ ] kidding me
uh did I tell the story on the podcast
about going to see The Thin Red Line and
the guys on the phone the whole time
just talking about what's on the screen
and he's blowing on his popcorn
Union Square I'm seeing The Thin Red
Line in the theater it's pretty packed
theater and uh
and this guy's on the phone and he's
just like describing what's on the movie
to his buddy like he's like kind of
talking he's sitting right behind me I'm
going crazy I'm getting I'm getting pit
so pissed off right and uh for me which
is you know it's like the feelings are
so deep down they're actually coming up
and um but he's he's also big and too
scary I can't there's nothing I can do
about it uh you know he'll Pummel me in
an instant uh but he's like you know
he's like he's on his phone and he's got
this weird habit of blowing on his
popcorn so he picks up his popcorn he's
like yeah on the screen I don't know
it's like a monkey right now
every piece one at a time and uh you
know ah this is [ __ ] weird there's
like two monkeys and I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this guy doing
well the the movie is is so like
powerful about like
I don't remember now like acceptance and
peace and love or whatever it is that
like by the end I'm like this that man
is the most beautiful man I love him I
love him blowing out his popcorn uh and
it didn't bug me at all but there's the
craziest thing I've never seen a guy
like blowing on his popcorn and talking
through the whole movie
I I it's not a good payoff to that story
I wish it doesn't it should be a better
there isn't well you didn't confront him
[ __ ] no
why would I mean you could always go
tell on him you could always go tell on
him you know just tattletail on him the
guy looked like uh
uh like uh
be wait you know WWE
ather like he was looking he was in
there looking for someone to respond to
him so that he could do something yeah
yeah I don't think so no I I think he
was on his own uh on his own thing I
think I think he was ready to I think
he's he's that's the kind of person
who's like I'm gonna do whatever the
[ __ ] I want because I want to get in a
fight
wait you guys want to hear something
funny yeah going back to the changing
your voice thing when I was uh really
feeling really sick I recorded my voice
because for whatever reason when I have
a really bad cold my I can get my voice
super low in a way that I can't ever get
it you want to hear it yeah sure we can
cut it off this doesn't play funny but
all right listen hold on
the gold I can get my voice down no
um normally again
but if I have gold again
foreign
I don't know if I'm allowed to tell this
story but I have a friend who is uh
practicing
um his James James Earl Jones
impersonation for uh for a gig where he
he was trying to basically do James Earl
Jones's voice and he was like the he's
like I have to do it I have to every
time I record I have to do it first
thing in the morning right when I wake
up
um and then for the rest of the day I
can't do it just because it's the only
time I can get that deep is first thing
in the morning
that's a good story
um so
okay let's try a little experiment just
because uh let's let's put some energy
into the pot two stories we're told and
by the way great attempts you're trying
to you're trying to find content for the
for the Pod but they didn't have great
endings now I wonder if you could retell
the story but make up an ending just
make up a completely different ending so
if Charlie whatever might have happened
a liar Rob
well but it could be fun to cut it into
the podcast have you tell that
incredible story and then we were going
back and it turns out that we yeah you
know what I'm saying okay so here we go
yeah so I've got I've got a friend on
I'm not gonna say who it is or why uh he
was doing this but he had to do James
Earl Jones's voice so he was practicing
doing James Earl Jones voice it was a
very distinct voice James Earl Jones as
we all know and it's very very deep and
the only time that my friend could ever
get it to sound like actual James Earl
Jones was when he first woke up in the
morning so this is the only time he
could record James Earl Jones's voice
was right first thing in the morning and
then the rest of the day he couldn't do
that anymore and then
and then I bought myself a muffin
and I ate it
[Laughter]
and it was delicious very good okay I'm
gonna try I'm gonna try so so I'm in the
movie theater with a guy right he's
blowing on his popcorn he's talking on
the on on the [ __ ] thing right and
and then he
think I already noticed God sorry
no no no no he eventually he's like hang
on I'm gonna put you on speaker because
he wants to eat more than like one piece
of popcorn yeah and he's got the other
guy on the speaker and the other guy
blowing up popcorn and he said and and
the guy's like hey what are you doing
you blowing on your popcorn he goes yeah
you blowing on popcorn he goes where are
you he goes I'm in a movie they're both
in a movie theater talking to each other
did you get a muffin
and then oh yeah and then I look under
the seat what's their free muffin
yeah that's always the best ending is
when there's a muffin at the end for you
to eat like that's that's what I'd find
is always the most satisfying ending
um how's that Rob did that that work for
you did that I thought you were gonna
say that you were you've eventually had
enough
and you told this guy to [ __ ] shut up
and he and he stood up and he turned
around and he was looming over you and
he was scary as [ __ ] and he was backlit
so you couldn't really get a good look
at him until the house lights came up
and you realized it was James Earl Jones
whoa oh my God crazy man crazy man James
Earl Jones gonna do something like that
he would never do so he's got too much
he's a classic guy let's talk about that
ball cap you're wearing in the episode
yeah that's a a real look
it's a real life because you had too
much hair to really get it flat so you
get that kind of like what's the most
fascinating look is the bald cap with
the two bag on top yeah and I remember
we were shooting in Philly obviously at
the at Logan Circle there um Logan
Square I believe it's called and
um and I remember the next morning
getting a bunch of calls and texts from
people saying uh Rob you're in a
newspaper you're in the newspaper and uh
you're in the inky which is the
Philadelphia Inquirer and sure enough
Inky uh on on the front page down in the
in the lower left hand side
it was telling the story about how we
were shooting in Philly and they used a
photograph of Danny and I walking and
I'm wearing the bald cap with no context
whatsoever I'm wearing the ball cap and
the wig and so many people were like
what's are you okay are you okay
what's wrong with you you're malaria or
something what's going on yeah
that's that's the one they went with no
context whatsoever I remember it just
said Danny DeVito and unknown actor
walking through the streets of
Philadelphia
[Laughter]
yeah that's always fun too is it and in
your hometown too where all your friends
and family can see it sure and yeah yeah
yeah and at a point where we could have
probably really used some good press
yeah you know yeah sure I've got some um
good photos of you directing or not
directing but like being behind camera
with that bald cap on like um Talking to
Rob Thomas and stuff I'll put them in
the Pod you must have worn it all day
when you were like not shooting yeah
because once once that thing goes on
it's it's hard to take it's hard to take
off so you just kind of keep it on and
shoot as much as you can yeah that's
that's why uh if you did a whole movie
of it you just gotta shave your head
take it from me
um I thought the erotic Tales was really
funny I I enjoyed you me too they
definitely made me laugh me too her
breasts were awesome
your balls totally rule yeah it's just
funny how he goes from eloquent to just
blunt
yeah it just kind of makes me uh want to
throw up a little bit I think it's I
think it's like I I think it's like I um
I don't want to be I don't want to be
associated with that man you know Dennis
Reynolds I don't want people to think
that I'm that I'm that person you know
but uh
and that's my cross to bear you know
yeah
it's my cross to bear guys I'm sorry I
gotta go to the bathroom
oh wow yeah I'm sorry
one or two vintage hey mind your own
business man uh all three
all three
What's Up Glamor now Meg anything
no guys I got nothing I'm halfway to a
nervous breakdown right now oh yeah why
is the dog yay that [ __ ] dog you're
just jealous because I pay attention to
anything that isn't you look at how cute
she is
it's like a Star Wars creature oh yeah
look at her Meg why are you halfway to a
nervous breakdown what's going on over
there I just had like a series of I
don't know like everything's been
hard lately yesterday uh there was a
some sort of water main break on the
street outside and we didn't have any
water in my house from 6 a.m to about 7
p.m at night
um and I had picked that day to go on
like a long run so I went out and did
like six miles and then I came home
and all I wanted was a [ __ ] shower
and there's not only no water in my
house but like no running water I can't
even have like a glass of water uh you
know and drinking tap water what do you
mean well no but yeah but like even the
filtered water that I have runs through
the the tap water runs through a filter
and so there's just no water coming out
and it's just been like a series of
stuff like that this week where like
everything that can go wrong does go
wrong so this is boring for the Pod
nobody cares about my I don't know I
think people want to hear but I think
people want to hear about
trials and tribulations well see this is
the problem though we've already we've
already established that we're not
allowed to really truly complain about
anything in our lives because uh you
know uh because we're
so many other people are less fortunate
than us and uh so we're I you know I'm
looking listen
I got a lot of stuff I complain about
okay let's get into that what's left if
you had to complain
if you had to complain about three
things that's all you had just three
things what would they be in no
particular order because we can ramp up
you can complain about the number of
things that Rob has allowed you to
complain about that could be one of them
but that seems like I'm just trying to
put some structure into it Meg I thought
you would appreciate that no well I do
think that I I do think that uh uh no
matter what level you are in your life
uh you know financially or whatever
um
there's always going to be some [ __ ] to
complain about you know what I mean
right I mean I think everybody can agree
on that I think it's just a matter of
like
um whether or not you decide to share
those things
you know uh because it's you know
like the other day when I was telling
the story about how I broke my toe
because you know my buddy and I were
headed down to my office and Jill came
out of her office and we established
that we've got two offices in our house
it's like once once you establish you've
got two offices in your house and uh
yeah you're just like I I can't I I
can't I can't complain about anything
man like I really can't I can't not in
public okay so okay so number one is
that you're complaining about not being
able to complain that's great that's a
good start I'm not complaining about not
being able to complain I actually
understand why
um but you know
it's you know I I do like to complain
and and it does it does hurt that I
can't
I like to come I can complain I can
complain about things like the way
people Park their cars and how it
affects
and how it affects me you know what I
mean because like that that's that
that's Universal you know what I mean
now if my projector breaks down in my
theater room in my house I probably
can't complain about that
well you could you could but you know
you just keep it off the air
yeah yeah so it's all about who you
complain to
yeah here's something I can complain
about when I was doing my run the other
day I got like body shamed by this
person that told me to wear some clothes
I was like running around and I haven't
I've been doing these longer runs and
super hot outside so for the first time
in my entire life I was running with
like a sports bra on and like then
leggings but like no tank top on because
it was like cooler that way and this
woman I ran past her and she goes wear
some clothes and I was like you're in
Los Angeles this is this is like Dowdy
for Los Angeles
oh 60s probably yeah next time next time
she was threatening next time just yell
back you felt that yell back I hope you
die I hope you die today
yeah well like you live in Los Angeles
like what oh I'm sorry you've never been
to the [ __ ] beach you've never been
to the beach
yeah and and like honestly what I was
wearing like most women wear to brunch
like just a sports bra and like that's
just like an LA staple and I was
actually wearing it to exercise during
like the hottest part of the day but um
you know there may only be five people
on Tick Tock who wear more than that
yeah the the balls on people though it's
like I love it a total stranger like you
don't know like that like you could turn
around and just beat her to death with a
rock
it is amazing how much how much women
have to deal with like Mega is always
telling me stories of my sister because
she runs a lot and Caitlyn how often
they have to like hear from anybody
whether it's male or female and I don't
think I've ever I don't think anybody's
ever yelled anything at me when I was
running ever yeah right have you ever
been like yelled at while you're walking
down the street or running I don't think
it's ever no but I'm no but I'm like
that guy in the movie theater with
Charlie like I I want I want it I want
it any excuse to just absolutely unleash
on somebody is is would be terrific yeah
I wish that you would get the experience
which I and many women have had so many
times of having a man stop you on the
street to tell you to smile which is so
like just a joy of women's lives to be
like just wandering around with a
neutral expression and have a man stop
you and be like hey you know we like the
best line ever heard is you forgot your
smile baby like and you're like no I
didn't I just have a neutral face
because I'm just walking down the street
and yeah
unfortunately my neutral fans I'm always
I'm always like think I'm always like
thinking about stuff like I you know I'm
just always like thinking of her I'm
like in my head about something and then
you know I walk into a room and and I
don't realize that I have this
expression on my face
[Laughter]
and I walk into a room and of course
inevitably somebody you know somebody's
like hey man are you are you okay and
I'm like
huh yeah I'm fine well you interrupted
my you know and then people you have
established that you hate when people
ask you if you're okay
I it irritates the [ __ ] out of me I'm
like don't [ __ ] just just do just why
I don't know I it's I know it shouldn't
[ __ ] why does that irritate me break
it down for me Rob like can you explain
why that irritates me so I hate it when
people ask me if I'm okay I think I have
a theory I have a theory are you okay
are you I think if I if I were to pull
you aside and say Glenn can I talk to
you for a second in fact I have done
this before and when I say
and I say you seem upset uh or agitated
or in pain or whatever it might be
are you okay is there anything I can do
for you would you like to talk about it
you're very receptive to that very
receptive indeed if someone walks up to
you and you seem annoyed or angry upset
or whatever and just goes what's wrong
are you are you all right it the
implication isn't I that I don't care
actually how you feel you're bringing an
energy into a room that I actually find
repulsive and I'm gonna call you out on
it okay you have just yes you've just
you've just put the put your finger on
it I think that's exactly what it is I'm
like I'm like
what the [ __ ] does whatever I'm thinking
about or what's going on with me have to
do with you you do you and I'll do me
and just [ __ ] off like like and if you
want to be in a good mood great be in a
good mood and guess what you're gonna
lift me up and I'll be in a good mood in
five seconds I'm not even in a bad mood
but now I am but that's the problem it's
like because usually usually it really
is me just like I'm thinking about
something and and I'm not in a bad mood
and then the person puts me in a bad
mood by asking me if I'm in a bad mood
that's the irony of it it's like they've
done the Office application isn't can I
help you the implication is hey change
your mood because it's bothering me it's
yeah yeah you're affecting you're
affecting my mood and I'm like I
shouldn't have that much power over you
I should I mean I understand why I do
I'm a very powerful presence I'm a
powerful man I bring a powerful energy
into the room and I get that I just
don't want that burden
and actually I subconsciously respect
you less for elevating me to that
specific status absolutely 100
absolutely yeah yeah because I don't
because I don't strike I don't strive
for that I don't want to be the person
who you know walks into a room and you
know affects everybody's mood but as
you've had to pull me aside when we were
you know as a as our working
relationship you pulled me aside I
remember specifically somewhere around
season six I started to lose my mind um
because I was like what is my list my
life now just this show like what is my
life you know I had so many other things
I wanted to do
um and I just was having like a little
bit of like a a crisis and um
and I was bringing a really kind of like
just sour energy I think to the set and
you know you pulled me aside because you
were like look I get it you're going
through some [ __ ] like and we can talk
about it and I'm happy to you know we
can talk about it uh whenever you want
um but you should just know and I like
that you put it this way because you
weren't telling me
you were you were just telling you were
basically saying like you should just
know that because you're the boss on
this show or one of the bosses on the
show
people are going to be affected by your
mood and that's just how it is like you
whatever energy you bring to set people
are going to be like oh oh you know
because already with you know the actors
on the show they everybody feels like
they have to accommodate that person
because if the actor is in a bad place
and the actor's in a bad mood you're
[ __ ] like you know the guy lighting a
scene can be in a bad mood and still
light the scene well but I can't be in a
bad mood and play a happy person or be
in a a really really shitty mood and you
know and be funny so all of a sudden
everybody's like oh okay I have to you
know everybody's walking on eggshells
and so you know that's that's what you
are pointing out to me and I was like
yep you're right you're 100 right yeah
but there's a way I'm sure like prior to
that I probably exacerbated any given
situation if you were to walk in like
that and I probably did a version of
what's wrong with you suck it up and
like and that's never gonna work right
it doesn't it doesn't that's not the way
human beings are you have to meet people
where they are and then and then accept
what the reality of the situation is and
then
help them you know find whatever
conclusion they're going to find but
like still like setting boundaries in a
safer environment as opposed to just
confronting somebody with how you feel
about the way that they feel which is
never going to work but there is still a
version of that conversation
that gets across the same information
but that's just more empathetic and
compassionate well it's also I've
noticed three of us have been in that
position too I think
um yeah absolutely over the course of
doing the show where
I think just had whether it's like
I don't know about a whole season maybe
but like days or episodes or weeks in
the writer's room it's usually just in
the writer's room because not you though
Charlie like as you've established you
just stuff it all down I I do stuff most
of it down but I think there's there's
been times like when the last few
seasons where I you know have been just
like burned out or something and we've
called each other out you get a little
snippy a little irritable or easily
easily you're yeah or like easily
offended or or something like that and
and yeah that's that's happened to you
too Rob where like yeah you're like a
little down and we have to we have to
talk about it but but the thing is is
like again it was a good way of
communicating it because you didn't tell
me what I had to do you were basically
just saying like hey just so you know
here's how your actions are making me
feel here's how what you're doing is
making us all feel
um you know what I mean and then when I
have to take it seriously it's like when
I see both of you guys like when I when
I when I see both of you come into a
room at the same time and one of you
says hey man we got to talk and the door
shuts I'm like
neither one of these guys is big on
confrontation and yet they're
confronting me about something so this
is a big deal
I already know that they've discussed it
outside of the room about how to handle
it and I'm immediately put in a position
of again this is coming from a place of
respect like I'm I already know I've
done something wrong that I need to
apologize for
and then you guys let me know what it is
and then I take in the information and
I'm almost 100 wrong uh every time and
then I apologize and try to do better
next time and we move forward
each one of us has been put in the hot
seat at one point or another being like
hey man XYZ doesn't work for the other
two of us you know so uh uh it's very
healthy but the the most healthy thing
is that all three of us miraculously
don't have that Gene to not hear that
you know where there's certain people
that you could be a partner with who
just would not hear it would not hear
the other two people would be like [ __ ]
you I'm not doing this and just couldn't
take it and I don't know what that is
but we we take our lumps well I think
some of us some of it really is the
approach I think the three of us at
least strive to be the kinds of people
that can deliver that information
without it
you know just being offensive or without
getting the person's defenses up without
you know like you have to be able to
communicate those things well otherwise
you know because if Rob had just pulled
me aside and been like hey dude you're
being a dick you're being a [ __ ] dick
and you need to stop like that would not
have worked like I would not have been
like you're right like that's not my
personality my personality had been like
hey man I'm going through some [ __ ] go
[ __ ] yourself like yeah I'm being a
[ __ ] dick like it just would have
made me more Angry you know what I mean
but because he communicated it well it
worked and it was effective in it and it
did kind of melt me in that moment like
I I felt my defenses I I actually
weirdly also
you know like you know in that moment
felt seen acknowledged you know what I
mean like it was it was a it was an
acknowledgment that didn't put me on my
heels didn't make me defensive and I I
mean I there's no way that the three of
us could have worked together for this
long without uh having those moments
where we had to pull one person aside
and be like hey what's going on because
you know this is what's happening and
this is how we see it and it's it's you
know
we need to talk about well this is all
leading to the moment Meg where where we
have to we have to talk to you the three
of us we've we've talked off camera and
this is the most see I have a secret
weapon which is I'm comfortable crying
in front of all of you and I don't think
you're as comfortable watching me cry as
I am comfortable well if Rob probably is
at this point but the other well no but
that's what we wanted to do that's
actually what we wanted I don't want to
see it but that's what we wanted to talk
to you about Meg we just want you to
smile more I mean I just wish you well
more yeah just smile it's so you know
it's so nice when you smile honey listen
whenever you feel sad
just smile and be glad and the feelings
will go away
[Laughter]
[Applause]
today we are sponsored in part by Zell
when anyone sends you money or if you
need to get paid back always ask for
Zell yeah with Zell see the money goes
straight into your bank account and it
works even if the sender Banks somewhere
different from you in the U.S oh that's
actually perfect because um you guys all
owe me for the t-shirts from tour what
are you talking about we we owe you
money we were paying no no yeah no yeah
yeah
remember
um that we decided beforehand that we
were all going to split the costs and
it's okay because you can just pay me
back on Zell it'll be really simple and
easy uh Meg I think it's that we got a
bad uh wiffy connection and maybe yeah
anyway when you use Zell the money sent
goes straight into your bank account
typically in minutes between enrolled
users well Zell is probably already in
your banking app because it's in over 1
600 different banking apps in the US so
you don't have to download a new app you
can just give me a check if you really
want to I just thought zelle would be
easier I'm hearing something but Meg I'm
not catching a lot of it there's a
terrible okay yeah I'm also not hearing
her in the meantime listeners look for
Zell in your banking app today
[Music]
you know it's a crazy and maddening part
of the experience is that
there is no like
one way to write an episode there is
like no correct way to do it and I don't
know about you guys I'm sure you feel
the same way
where I'm going back and I'm watching
all the episodes and I'm trying to
I sort of watch everything analytically
right like what worked what didn't work
so much how can we do better how can I
do better with this show or other things
that I might try to write I I can't I
have a hard time ever turning that those
questions off but
the truth is I
I'm nowhere closer to An Answer than we
when we first started doing the show
like I don't really know why one episode
of Sunny
is a home run and another one is like ah
not doesn't quite add up I haven't
figured that out are you guys excited to
get back into the writer's room this
year because we're yeah actually I had a
couple good ideas that I I wrote some
notes down that I might say but I'm
excited to share with you guys
ideas that we can just turn into eight
episodes and be done with it it's one
idea it's definitely one episode
I'm excited about the prospect of
bringing the podcast into the writer's
room and having people take a look at
how we start the show it might be really
fun to do a podcast episode that's Soup
To Nuts an entire episode an empty white
board with no ideas how do we turn that
into a fully realized episode of sunny
and do a podcast about that I think that
could be fun kind of interesting yeah
that'd be interesting for sure
I wonder could could but we'd have to
we'd have to hold that probably until
after we aired the episode or no you
think we could actually air that I mean
but why not yeah yeah maybe or or maybe
we drop it in installments at the same
time on Hulu at the same time that the
episode comes out we could do that uh
well uh I've got no ideas
um going into this next season uh I'm
terrified to go back in the writer's
room uh the first couple days are always
really fun because we're just getting
you know we're getting back in a room
together and you know everybody's
there's that Energy's popping you know
and we're making fun of what everybody's
wearing and you know they're weird hats
and hairdos and who's going gray and all
that kind of stuff and it's all fun and
games it's it's better not to come in
with ideas I feel like because they get
stale right like if you have an idea
like those first couple note cards like
almost never get used you know like that
the first episode you break is always
the one you're like that one I don't
know like yeah it's like yeah you've got
all these great ideas for these great
episodes and then everybody's just like
yeah but I kind of like the cat in the
wall one yeah really yeah
no but you got to come in with I mean
it's just they're all just jumping off
points you know what I mean uh it's good
to have some jumping off points Meg do
you have ideas for this season
um I have one idea but I've already
pitched it to you guys last season which
is just that um the the gang
oh yeah that's right oh yeah
but truly I I can't pitch things like
this but the thing I the podcast has
made me want to do is just more like
really simple stories about like
somebody wanting to be somebody's best
friend or like you know like just this
even this episode the idea of just
starting out with
um Charlie and Dee being like you
couldn't walk a mile in my shoes it's
such a funny jumping off point for like
an episode and it's so small it's not
like based on current events or like
anything like that and I really enjoy
that stuff so I guess I'm gonna Endeavor
to try to pitch stuff like that yeah
well it's really funny right because
that's going back to what I was saying
about like it's so hard to kind of crack
crack that nut right so like uh Mac and
Dennis break up or whatever such a funny
episode like uh you know these like
really small personal ones that all take
place on our sets and in our Apartments
can be so fun and yet
the one where we go to the water park is
just fantastic or the Jersey Shore right
so you know it's it's just hard it's
hard to know I guess you got to do it
all you gotta try different things
that's that's the gig right we're just
trying different things with these
characters and um
hopefully most the time it works and
sometimes but we've tried them all it's
not as strong as the next one but uh
that's the beauty television you got the
next episode to go improve by why are
you shaking your head Rob's shaking this
because no go sorry because Glenn said
we tried them all but we haven't we
haven't we have we have we're only
halfway through the Run bud
halfway through yeah
foreign